and we let lowercase b be the outcome of the measurement of the qubit Q.
Alice then sends those
two classical bits to Bob and this is the only communication that's involved in this protocol and that's indicated in the diagram
by the fact that these two
bits cross the dotted line between Alice and Bob,
which you can think of as representing whatever
distance separates them.
After Bob receives the bits
a and b, he does two things.
First, if a is equal to one, then he performs an X
operation or in other words, a NOT gate on his qubit B,
and otherwise if a is equal to zero, then he doesn't do that.
And along similar lines,
if b is equal to one, then Bob performs a Z operation
or a Z-gate or a phase flip
also on the qubit b and like
before, if b is equal to zero, then he doesn't do that.
This is all indicated in the figure where we have these controlled-X
and controlled-Z gates where the controls are
the two classical bits.
You don't have to think of these gates as being control gates
if you don't want to, this is just a handy way
to express what we want
in the form of a circuit diagram. The point is that Bob applies
an X-gate to the qubit b if a is equal to one and
then he applies a Z-gate
to the qubit b if B equals one.
And for the sake of convenience later we can write down explicitly
the combined operation that Bob performs on his qubit b,
depending upon the classical
bits that Alice sends.
So that is the teleportation protocol, it's pretty simple really, the
fact that it actually works is a different matter
and although the analysis
isn't that complicated,
you should not feel that you're missing something if you don't immediately see why it works.
That's why we need to
go through an analysis and that's what we will do next.
To analyze the teleportation protocol, we'll work through it one step at a time to see what the states
of the three Qubits are at different points in time.
We're gonna first consider
the case that the top qubit is in the state AlphaZero plus beta one, where alpha and beta
are any complex numbers
that cause this vector
to be a unit vector.
This is the qubit Q that
Alice is trying to transmit, but we don't really care what
it's called at this moment.
A little bit later, we'll
take a look at the situation in which this qubit is
entangled with another system, but this is a good starting
point just to keep things simple
and to see how the analysis
works a little bit more clearly.
If we consider the state of
the three Qubits together here at the start, we see
that this state has the form that you see right here.
The first two Qubits are
in the Phi plus state, the third qubit is the top one
according to the convention
for ordering Qubits that I
described in the previous lesson, and so we take the tensor product to get the state of the
three Qubits together.
We can expand this expression
by first substituting the definition of the Phi plus state and then computing the tensor product
and we get the state
that you see right here.
It's not always the best
strategy by the way, to completely expand
out a vector like this, it's generally a good idea to wait until
you have a good reason to do this.
But here we do have a reason, which is that we would
like to compute the action of this controlled NOT gate and by writing in the state in this form,
we can very easily do that.
And in particular, this is
the state of the three Qubits after the controlled NOT gate is applied.
The third qubit is the control qubit because that's the one that's
on top by our convention, and the second qubit,
which is the middle one,
is the target, so we just
operate on the cats accordingly, if the third bit is a
zero, nothing happens,
and if the third bit is a one,
then we flip the second bit.
Then we perform the Hadamard
gate on the third qubit, we can write the resulting
vector like you can see
right here substituting the
plus and the minus state for the zero and the one state.
And if we wanna have enough
room to expend this one out, we're gonna need to shrink
it down a little bit and now, by substituting the
plus and the minus states
with their definitions,
bringing the square root of two into the denominator, we get the state that you see right here.
And by expending that one out, we get the state that you see right here.
So, that is the state of the three Qubits after Alice performs her two operations.
Alice then measures
and if we wanna analyze the measurements, what we do is to isolate the standard basis vectors
for the systems being measured
just like we talked about in lesson two, and if we do that in this particular case, this is what we obtain.
And if you look at that
expression for a moment, it might seem a little bit peculiar because now it looks like the first qubit,
which is the bottom qubit
somehow depends upon alpha and beta, even though at
this point there hasn't been any communication across the dotted line,